let's talk about Marjorie Taylor green
on 60 Minutes dozens of you wrote to me
as many people wrote to me as the number
that protested for Trump at Mar-A-Lago
dozens dozens of you wrote to me and
said David what is your take about 60
Minutes interviewing Marjorie Taylor
green they are platforming a lunatic
they are pretending as though they're
normalizing the idea of Marjorie Taylor
green as someone who should be in
government it's just a matter of do we
agree about reviews rather than making
her out to be the dangerous extremist
who has no business in a position of
power I tweeted yesterday I understand
the concerns and I want to see the
interview first and the reason I said I
want to see the interview first is I've
long advocated for something called
responsible platforming and by
responsible platforming I mean
it's not about who you interview
it's how you interview them and so for
example when I have someone on the show
who is explaining uh nuclear fission to
us as a subject matter expert I handle
that interview differently than when I
interviewed interviewed for example a
white nationalist Neo-Nazi Richard
Spencer if I'm an average of Spencer on
I need to be prepared to make sure that
my audience understands his extremist
ideas are dangerous that they're bogus
and so on and so forth I think people
get this the point is the interview's
appropriateness is evaluated based on
how the interview is handled and it
wasn't handled the best by Leslie Stahl
but it wasn't the end of the world
overall I don't like that I think the
interview did normalize Marjorie Taylor
green to a degree
that's where I come down it wasn't it
wasn't overall a a softball interview
but there were moments that weren't so
good let's look at just a couple of
moments here's one question about
whether Marjorie Taylor green has
deliberately styled herself after Donald
Trump how much have you styled yourself
and why don't we have audio here
I'm not sure who is ah we do have audio
my headphone has become unplugged let me
plug that back in beautiful all right
let's take it from the top how much have
you styled yourself after Donald Trump
hmm people say and by the way this look
from Marjorie Taylor green one thing I
want to say and I won't harp on it is
Green's attitude the entire interview
was sort of of like this isn't a serious
show Leslie Stahl isn't serious and I'm
above this this is just me placating the
fake news and it was pretty disgusting
but let's not harp on that that you are
Trump in high heels I didn't
intentionally sound myself after
president Trump but I can see how people
draw those similarities so we both come
from the same industry construction
um I also have pretty much a plain
speaking style yeah and and so does he
okay so a little bit fluffy a little bit
fluffy one of the better moments was
when Leslie Stahl was prepared with fact
checks and tweets and everything to
question Marjorie Taylor green about
things she had previously said including
that the Parkland shooting was a false
flag and other things Marjorie Taylor
green basically just denies it but I do
think this was one of the stronger parts
of the interview let's take a look
shortly after she arrived in Washington
the democratic-led house
ousted her from her committees because
of her past endorsement of violence
against some democratic leaders and her
history of embracing Q Anon that she
explained in a speech on the house floor
I stumbled across something and this is
at the end of 2017 called Q Anon I was
allowed to believe things that weren't
true and that is absolutely what I
regret well I apologize to my colleagues
I think apologies are important
okay did you ever apologize to Nancy
Pelosi
about the bullet to her head I didn't
say that so I don't need to apologize
for the words that won't you like it
other people also ran my social media so
now it's like listen person the party of
personal responsibility that was other
people well if other people liked
something about Nancy Pelosi needs a
bullet to the head and you don't agree
with it shouldn't you loudly denounce
the sentiment oh no other people run my
social media I don't think I did that
are you saying that you don't stand by
what's on your social media well of
course I stand for what's on my social
media but at times not you're not always
in control we have all kinds of people
that work on Art so it's not your fault
oh okay got it well great responsibility
huh special media did you apologize for
your position on Parkland Florida what
was my position on Parkland Florida that
it was a false I don't know if you
actually have my position no I never
said Parkland was a false did you okay
so there's a post it's called the payoff
to keep his mouth shut since it was a
false flag plan shooting to which
Marjorie Taylor green responded exactly
hmm oh I've never said that school
shootings are horrible I don't think
it's anything to joke about we fact
checked before I got to this interview
have you fact checked all my statements
from kindergarten through 12th grade
okay that's called the red herring not
not at issue she's denying having said
things that are on the record in college
and as I've paid my taxes and never
broken a law and the only I got a few
speeding tickets do we need to remember
it doesn't have anything to do with
breaking the law it's she's denying
having said things that she said this is
how you try to distract talk about those
two because I think where you're going
down is the same attacks that people
have attacked me with over and over and
over she means holding me accountable
for things I've said well if this is
what you're known for I think it's good
that you're responding to the charges I
think I think I think it's a legitimate
because people for us to constantly
focus on it but never focus on anything
good about me there is nothing good
that's the pro I mean this it's a sad
thing but she's done nothing good since
coming to Congress she's only had this
path of Destruction where she harasses
the victims of school shootings spreads
conspiracy theories spreads medical
disinformation and then she's never held
accountable for it so this is an attempt
to ask her about the things she's done
which are basically saying horrible
things
they button this up and we'll move on
you want to bring the Republican Party
closer to your views you want to bring
the country closer to your views you've
said that okay I here are some of the
things you've said
um that America should have a Christian
government that abortion should be
banned nationally that you want to
defund the FBI
yes
you want immigration to stop for four
years you've said those things correct
oh yeah these are these are some of my
views the Constitution the very first
amendment prohibits having a religion in
the government
yet the founding fathers quoted the
Bible constantly and were driven by
their faith
that's a total cop-out by the way
there's a
reporter of the now indicted Donald
Trump
she was a featured speaker at his rally
in Waco last weekend while she's adored
here the latest National poll has her
approval rating at just 29
Marjorie Taylor green you happen to be
here
foreign
would you like to run for the Senate and
I will fight like hell for you I thought
the question for her and the country is
can she expand her Brash MTG brand
beyond the right-wing populist base I
believe the answer is obviously not so
listen some fact checking there
certainly Marjorie Taylor green is a
narcissist much like Trump and so you
never really get her because no matter
how you push her eventually she'll say
she's being misquoted or you don't
understand or she's actually correct or
whatever the case may be one other
moment I do want to show you from this
interview and I would I would watch the
whole thing if you you know really want
to understand the full scope of it she
said actually the government the US
government really isn't worthy of much
respect and deserves to be attacked but
also he's often an attack mode
and you appear to be
yet I think but I think our government
deserves it they don't really deserve to
be respected that much right and of
course the government that doesn't
deserve much respect and deserves to be
attacked is the one that she works in
and makes 175 000 a year for doing and
is paid through the taxpayer uh funded
salaries of everyone that is in her
position but it's a it's an entity that
should be attacked
so overall this interview was an
atrocity it was more an atrocity because
of the things that Marjorie Taylor green
said I don't think that there's some of
you came away from this saying this was
a total puff piece and it's horrible
what Leslie Stahl did
others came away saying it's amazing how
Marjorie Taylor green was held
accountable by by Leslie Stahl I think
that there were some really good
attempts to hold her accountable she's
really slippery like Trump is slippery
and her base is not going to think twice
about supporting her based on this
interview we all understand it for what
it is so I don't know that damage was
done but I don't know let me put it this
way I don't know that damage was done to
Marjorie Taylor Green's reputation and I
don't know that the interview was too
damaging to 60 Minutes my preference
would have been
not to have her on there at all after
seeing this interview I want to hear
from you let me know what you think